in the year 2000 a wealthy bostonian
named julian west woke up from a very
long nap he had fallen asleep in the
year
1887. the united states in the year 2000
was very different from the gilded age
he knew it was a utopian society where
there was no poverty no labor strikes no
pollution his new friends in the future
explained to him how this society worked
there was no private property
and no money everyone worked at the job
they were most suited for and received
their fair share of the national wealth
on a credit card that they could use to
buy necessities
this is the plot of edward bellamy's
1888 novel looking backward it was a
bestseller of its day but today we
remember it not only for its predictions
about the future but as an example of
how thinkers of the time period explored
the burning question of the gilded age
was it possible to have a modern
industrial society without great
inequalities of wealth in the late 19th
century the rapid changes in american
life stemming from the rise of
industrial capitalism caused a great
deal of concern the united states prided
itself on being different from the
countries of europe where the inequality
between the aristocracy and the working
class caused strife and revolution but
industrialization had brought both
millionaires and impoverished millions
to the united states packing them into
cities where mansions sat side by side
with filthy tenements suddenly the new
world looked a lot more like the old
world and so people at the time wondered
was inequality an inevitable byproduct
of advancing society those who answered
yes were called social darwinists who
thought that the survival of the fittest
would weed out the weak and improve
society overall we'll talk more about
social darwinism elsewhere but in this
video i want to concentrate on those who
believe that it was possible to have a
society that was both modern and
equitable during the gilded age there
were a number of reformers and reform
movements that attempted to solve the
problems posed by urban and industrial
life so let's talk about some of the
ways that reformers attempted to respond
to the inequalities of the gilded age
one was to suggest new economic systems
for the united states for example you
might have noticed that in edward
bellamy's utopian society there was no
private property and the national wealth
was equally shared in fact what he was
suggesting was socialism a system in
which the government not private
individuals owns economic enterprises
bellamy carefully avoided saying the
word socialism which was associated with
anarchists and immigrant radicals but he
portrayed it as the ultimate remedy to
all problems in the country bellamy's
work influenced many reformers including
the labor activists and socialist leader
eugene v debs who ran for president on a
socialist platform five times another
popular suggestion of the time was the
single tax which was proposed by henry
george in his book progress and poverty
george's solution to wealth inequality
was to replace all other taxes with a
single high tax on the value of land he
believed that the revenue from this tax
would be enough to pay for all necessary
government services one of georgia's
many admirers was jacob reese he was a
social reformer who published a photo
expose of tenement life in new york city
called how the other half lives reese
was one of the first muckrakers whose
chosen method of combating social
problems was to shine a light on them
his images of dangerous living
conditions in tenements led to laws
which regulated building safety other
muckrakers targeted the corruption in
industry like ida tarbell who wrote a
history of the standard oil company that
exposed its unscrupulous practices
some focused on the unjust treatment of
racial minorities in 1881
helen hunt jackson published a book
called a century of dishonor which
discussed the mistreatment violence and
broken treaties that indigenous
americans had faced at the hands of the
u.s government and white settlers
journalist ida b wells campaigned
against the lynching of black men in the
south in addition to campaigning against
economic and social inequality many
gilded age reformers attempted to remedy
the problems befalling cities and their
residents the most famous of these was
the settlement house movement settlement
houses were community centers based in
immigrant neighborhoods where newcomers
could learn english get job skills
obtain child care and find a range of
services that help them adapt to life in
urban america jane adams founded whole
house in chicago in 1889 and many other
reformers founded settlement houses in
other cities similarly some churches of
the time period began to emphasize that
confronting contemporary social problems
and helping the poor were the embodiment
of the teachings of christianity this
social gospel movement as it was known
led to the establishment of missions in
urban areas and churches opened
libraries gymnasiums and classrooms for
public use some reformers focused their
energies on the physical setting of
cities believing that the squalor of
dirty streets and tenements depressed
people and encouraged moral decay the
city beautiful movement worked to
incorporate parks inspiring architecture
and good design into american cities
frederick law olmsted designed central
park in new york city to be a respite
from the urban jungle and city beautiful
architects like daniel burnham created
monumental spaces and buildings in
washington dc these spaces were supposed
to inspire harmony order and civic
virtue in society one aspect of gilded
age reform you may have noticed by now
is that a large number of reformers were
women jane adams ida b wells and ida
tarbell all played prominent roles in
the movement after the civil war a
growing number of middle class women
went to college and these active and
educated women began looking for work
and meaning outside of the home many
white middle and upper class women
joined clubs dedicated to social reforms
and they argued that women's traditional
role of keeping their homes clean and
the people within them upstanding and
moral also extended to their communities
which they called municipal housekeeping
the women's christian temperance union
for example became the gilded ages
largest female organization with more
than 150 000 members led by francis
willard the wctu grew from its roots in
opposing the sale and consumption of
alcohol to advocate for policy solutions
to social problems ranging from prison
reform to domestic violence the wctu
also campaigned for women's suffrage in
1890 the two major women's suffrage
organizations which had been at odds
with each other since the passage of the
15th amendment reunited to form the
national american woman suffrage
association their efforts would lead to
the growth of woman suffrage at the
state level and later with the help of
the national women's party the passage
of the 19th amendment to the u.s
constitution